hey driver yes ma'am let's play a game
what would you do if you knew tonight
was your last night under
wow i'm a pretty chill guy i just live
with my brother i go to school
come on driver last night on earth drugs
women men old enemies you're just
waiting to
i'll definitely kill you finally he
bites back
we're hitting every single one of these
parties tonight and we need to get to
the last stop by morning
here's the first town oh [ __ ] the devil
is calling love level has fallen total
never stalling heavy metal
look at it looks like a butler or
something y'all
[Music]
who do you think runs the city we are
richer and more powerful than you could
ever imagine
moving right under your noses
[Music]
there's these two women right and i've
been driving them around all night
there's something weird going on
i need you to be smart
do you do anything stupid like try and
run i'm going to kill you
sweet uh okay great
might get a little messy in there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't think i've ever met anybody like
you
what what is wrong with you you can't be
alive for 200 years and not go a little
crazy
[Music]
you